hello friends I'm Ilana and welcome to
my channel for those of you who don't
already know me I'm Australian but I've
been living in the United States of
America for five years now and I just
recently went home for Christmas it was
my first time going home in a year and a
half
wait wait way too long and God being
home makes me so happy it's just because
it's familiar it's what I grew up with
it's people I know and a lot of phrases
that I know that I forgot about so I was
inspired to make this video when I was
home I consulted just people I came
across at Baz family friends to make
this video of some of my favorite
Australian slang I actually came up with
the idea to make this because I ordered
drink in a bar and the bartender said
I'll put this into context in the video
but she said it's a bit how you going
and that was a phrase that I had not
heard and so long but I had completely
forgotten existed but I just love
because it's so Australia and so silly
but first off I didn't want to say all
proceeds to this video will go to
charities that are supporting that are
against the fire supporting the fire
relief efforts I'll also leave a link in
the description below to where you can
donate if you haven't already seen me
very aggressively telling people to do
that
and to everyone who is Aussie my family
was okay for the record where I went
home for Christmas completely safe no
smoke even I'm very asthmatic so if
there even a lick of smoke I would have
been in a lot of trouble but I was
completely fine one half of my family is
completely okay the other half of my
family has not been so lucky and has
been evacuated and have had fears that
their house would be burned to the
ground which luckily has not happened
yet so of course it is what it is but it
was honestly like I opening Lee amazing
the amount of people who asked if my
family was okay and yeah I just wanted
to say thank you it's been very very
sweet I didn't know that many people
cared so thank you okay - the quotes
we're gonna start with that first one I
mentioned which is it's a bit how you go
I went to order a cider and the woman at
the bar said we give this one out in a
wineglass instead of in like a regular
pint glass because it's a bit how you
going if I weave with you in person
right now I would ask you what you think
this means before telling you what
actually does mean in this context she
was telling me the drink was strong she
was saying that the percentage of this
side I was a lot higher than a normal
side uh it's a bit how you going meaning
strong but often that phrase can mean
bad or more it's more average or can
even mean intense like it can kind of
mean anything depending on how you say
in the context you say it so if it's
like bad it'd be like are you going o
intend to be it's a bit how you going
but it varies again beautiful very
Australian very silly slang there's
another one that I you really love that
I used to use a lot old mate if someone
is old mate it's basically just well
it's basically just the phrase that you
use for someone whose name you don't
remember or have never known old mate
down the road yeah old mate old mate
with the car yeah she's dating old mate
just in lieu of using someone's name you
use the phrase old mate it is never used
as an insult it's just like all mate
whatever I'm not here to [ __ ] spiders
I've seen people argue on the internet
that this one is not really used and was
invented by social media but it's
definitely really used at least in
Queensland it is I'm not here to [ __ ]
spiders means it's the same as like does
the best [ __ ] the woods if you say if
you take someone to an Italian
restaurant and you say so do you want to
eat they would say I'm not here to [ __ ]
spiders because naturally yes they're
obviously that eat they are not there to
engage in intercourse with arachnids a
variation of that that my cousin told me
is I'm not here to put food on
centipedes I've never heard anyone say
that he could have been lying to me
bloody oath that's a good one
so also really hard to explain bloody
oath generally will mean like absolutely
yes or like I know you're talking about
or I agree
someone could say it's hot today you'll
be like bloody oath you can also kind of
say it in surprise or like like
enthusiastic surprise like someone could
say I really like rise of the Skywalk
and you really bloody oath servo is a
service station which in the u.s. is
predominantly called a gas station or a
petrol station blinder is a phrase to
mean full-on you'd say something
was applying its a blinder it's gonna be
a blinder can mean like a huge party or
say you work in retail we have Boxing
Day sales in Australia so you might say
yeah it's gonna be a blinder as in a lot
of people will be there chock-a-block
also shortened to chacas is similarly
something being very full if something
is full-on full really really busy Issei
is chock-a-block or it's chalk is crack
the shit's I think this is just
Australia I'm not actually show haha and
I like some of these like people in the
UK use as well I don't know if I've had
crack the shit's before though that's
basically like when someone is chucked
to tantrum dag I like that one I missed
that would a dag is someone who is a lot
of people will say nerdy I don't think
dag really means nerdy it's more like
dorky woah could be awkward I guess but
like my parents called me a dag when I
was a kid not that I wasn't well now I
was nerdy so maybe it is that for being
just like silly and a little bit aloof I
think if someone's a dag it's like yeah
he's dagi just be that's a hard one to
explain I'm sorry
any Australians who want to help out in
the comments please let me know dead set
dead set is I probably often use his
like yeah dad said it means like 100
percent I am dead set on this I don't
know I am very set on this dead set flat
out we have a lot of words that mean the
same thing flat out is very similar to
chocolate buck chuck is a blind almost
flat out it's like it was flat out means
it was full-on 100% it was busy it was
whatever probably usually used in terms
of like work like how was walk today be
like it's flat out it would be like
hugely busy [ __ ] me dead doesn't sound
as good in my accident because I don't
have like a very like thickest ralien
accent my whole family sounds very
similar to how I sound for the record it
[ __ ] me dead sounds but if you sound
kind of more regional which is like [ __ ]
me dead which is just like surprised
it's like it's like an oh my god it's a
shock
[ __ ] be dead it could also be annoyed
like hard Yakka is hard work piece of
piss finally one that means easy we have
a lot of words for things being hard
Australians are very laid-back people we
love a good relaxed yeah piece of piss
basically just means it was a piece of
cake but of course because it's
Australia we have to put fecal matter in
it and make it piece of piss that one
when I heard it often not hearing it for
a long time was like why do we why are
we like this
Oh beautiful nation what I hope this is
making any of you who are learning about
these things as happy as it's making me
to talk about these things
whoop-whoop is the middle of nowhere
he's out in whoop-whoop she lives in
whoop-whoop we're passing
buh-buh-buh-buh literally just means the
middle of nowhere that's it that's the
only way to describe it no Walker's is
no worries a dull blodger that's a good
one a dull bludger is the name for
someone who it takes government benefit
money and is lazy so like intentionally
isn't really doing anything if someone's
a dull blodger yeah they're just taking
the minimum amount of money that they
can get from the government and not
working I'm not really trying to I think
it's not often said with hate though
it's like just kind of a way of calling
someone lazy it's not said with the like
extreme anger that I've seen it said in
other countries I guess it probably is
sometimes it for the most part is lady's
adult blogger Anya is short for good on
you but mostly said with sarcasm Anya
it's both ony a like yeah anya anya mate
is like it's someone that makes a
mistake or [ __ ] up or does something
stupid you would usually say anya bloody
rippa again another one that sounds
better stronger accent Vladdy Arriba is
something's very good a Bingle is a car
crash tanked if you're very tanked you
got tanked she's tanked is just very
drunk shonky is dodgy something was
built in a way that chunky has caused a
bit shonky it's probably not well put
together you're worried it might break a
fall apart
knock off I feel like other countries
use this
knock off this when you finish work so
what time you knock off we knock off
early on a Friday means you'd finish
early on a Friday crook as it's all just
sewed up crook as just means you're
really sick and a loss when I have on
this list is she'll be right which is
most often said should we right so you'd
make it a full word rather than she'll
be right you'd say she'll be right this
one can also kind of mean a lot of
things she'll be right is basically
saying it'll be okay but I feel like
it's most often said with the tone of
like it should be right maybe like
something's like slightly wrong with a
car but you've mostly put it back
together be like a should be right it's
kind of like oh it also a like don't
worry about it it's good I got it but
you can't also refer to it like as a
person hard to explain she'll be right
is hard to explain it's just like it'll
be fine and that's all the Australian
slang when I had completely forgotten
about that I have listed I feel like
some of these probably will be used in
other countries as well I'm not sure I
didn't actually want to Google most of
these because I wanted to make sure that
was my interpretation of him not
something that I read on the internet so
I wanted to make sure I kept it
authentic and if anyone thinks they can
explain something better than I did
because I don't feel like I did a great
job
feel free to anyone from other countries
is watching you know feel free to let me
know your favorite slang cuz I find this
stuff very dumb and very fun thank you
again everyone who's been asking if my
family's okay I'm glad to report
everyone is okay if a little stressed in
some parts right now and for everyone
who's watching from back home my
thoughts are with all of you I hope
you're all okay alrighty everyone I'm
Alana I'll see you guys next time